good morning millennials
welcome back to the toast and happy
Monday hope everyone had a fabulous
holiday weekend hey Jax how you doing
I'm doing great I had a great holiday
weekend I've missed everyone here at the
toast it's been a nice break but I'm so
excited and ready and happy to be back I
can't believe Thanksgiving was like four
days ago and we haven't spoken since
Thanksgiving no and also the way we like
left the episode on Wednesday with I
didn't even realize people were so
invested in the deer toaster Saga like
the way we just did that and then I'm
not having another episode until Monday
and thank God we got an update so if
you're following us on Instagram
good for you because you weren't left
wondering all weekend what happened to
the girl with her dog we posted an
update and it was really jarring she got
her dog back she made her husband listen
to the episode so he could see how
psychotic his behavior was and two
people who have no particular stake in
the matter think that his behavior is
wild so maybe sometimes you just have to
see yourself sometimes you need a big
mirror and um where he left the dog for
those wondering he hired a dog sitter on
Rover which is like fine but like not
you know not really it's like a stranger
now when you have two Like Loving
parents at home who are available and
wanting to be with their dog right
right
um so it was a fabulous holiday weekend
I saw you really turned it out with your
hosting skills it looked beautiful it
was it all really went according to plan
like I did so much prep the night before
as much as I could do I actually wish
that I had done even more and I
definitely had some learnings for next
year like first biggest learning is all
of the herbs I would pre-chop all of
them I would have a bowl that was
Rosemary a bowl that was thyme because
chopping it per recipe was brutal and
that was like one of the tedious things
that really got to me so I'd have a huge
bowl of chopped thyme chopped Rosemary
chopped oregano whatever chops are
needed because I did prep most of the
veggies like I sliced all of my
squash with my mandolin do you see my
circular squash I did those
sweet potato Stacks uh they were really
really cool and I did as much as I could
but I probably could have done even more
prep but the day of cooking was so much
fun Olivia came over with the kids we
cooked even more it was just really like
a classic Thanksgiving and I do feel
like Thanksgiving changes once you have
kids it just takes on a whole new
meaning and also you want to start like
New Traditions and it's just really fun
and really sweet and I have to say we
watched the parade from start to finish
because we are now up at those hours and
it was so amazing first of all Harry's
not someone that you could just like put
in for at least not yet I think he's a
little young you can't like put in front
of the TV yet and he's entranced for
more than five minutes
he loved the parade the way he loved
this parade I've never really seen him
so invested in something it made me it
made me want to set new goals for myself
and work really hard so that I can go to
the parade one day like for work and get
like a backstage access or we could get
someone's apartment on Central Park West
did you see there were a few people who
tagged us in their setups they didn't
invite us no they did not
bragging about their setups but no I
like I of course he would never turn
down a Park View sitting next to a
fireplace all cozied up but like I want
to get us on the sidelines one year and
I feel like let me tell you podcaster as
a host as an influencer like it's not
that crazy there are so many different
like Brands and networks that like
activate there and so that's a new goal
of mine and I I don't want to be like in
the back row like let me let me tell you
like
sideline or bust it's a great goal but I
do think it's worth mentioning that like
I think the Thanksgiving Day parade is
like many you know big televised events
like actually better to watch from home
um like the Super Bowl you know it's a
lot of people's you know dream to go to
the Super Bowl let me tell you I've been
twice and it's way better on TV you
don't even get to see the commercials
when you're there good luck seeing the
halftime show it's not it's not like a
concert it's made for TV the microphones
aren't even on they're plugged into the
TV yet but the experience is better like
honestly when we went to the Super Bowl
that was a much more amazing experience
than having a Super Bowl party at home
if I was someone so invested in the game
and don't want a distraction I just want
to be like zoomed in on my favorite
players yeah I probably want to watch
from home but it was the experience but
it was the weekends
where their people are where the
performers perform in one part of the
parade and then there's like bleachers
behind them
those seats or bust because those people
get the performances it's up close
there's not that many seats so that's
what I'm interested in or bust for me
the Super Bowl like the weekend was so
fun like because it was very like
celebrity like pop in and there was lots
of cool events but when it comes to
actually like watching something I think
a lot of the times it's better to do
from home like even the Thanksgiving Day
Parade we've went to the parade because
we live in New York obviously
um we've like you know tried to like
spectate every street is closed it's
freezing you can never get to where you
need to go it's like low-key torture I
just think it's one of those things that
might be better in theory than in
practice I'm saying like I want to get
to Al Roker seat and then you can enjoy
the parade I think I'd rather be caught
like at a Central Park West on someone's
gorgeous balcony with a fireplace a
spread of food now there's an outdoor
fireplace on the balcony hmm now there's
an outdoor fireplace on the balcony
did I say that you said yeah and
someone's balcony with a fireplace Well
yeah if they have a balcony I could go
outside I get a little cold to go inside
to the fireplace there's a smorgasbord
inside maybe we're playing board games
we're listening to music it's very
comfortable but then if I really wanted
to like really see the balloons up close
I'd go on their gorgeous balcony
understood I'm not picky though if you
have a balcony or not a balcony you
could still invite me I just I need to
see pics before maybe next year we'll
have like more
generous toasters who want to invite you
to their setup because people were
tagging us in their gorgeous setups but
narian invite was scored nearly an
invite but that's the thing it's like if
somebody actually had invited me it's
like a premium spot I would have had to
show up two days before because the
streets are closed like you can't even
get to your building when you actually
live near the Macy's Thanksgiving Day
Parade it is laced with a little bit of
torture yes oh for sure for sure for
sure I had one more thought about oh no
I had a lingering question when was the
second time you went to the Super Bowl
we went to Minnesota Minnesota yeah of
course could never forget
so we only do it once the breath yeah it
was one you know it was a moment in time
oh really I don't know why I thought we
went like we something we did like CMAs
like every year no I know I only went
once but I thought maybe you went
another time with your people no then I
have only been with you
right yeah I've only been once
okay I guess I've only been once and it
was enough for me honestly Diana no I
like got the experience it was amazing
so glad that I had it I'm not running to
do it again right
um and after the holiday I went to
Brian's horse farm and when I tell you
I'm not okay I
did not realize like when I was riding
the horse I went riding on Saturday
how incapacitated I would be when I tell
you I can't even sit on the toilet like
I'm in so much pain right now the back
of my thighs it's like it's a tightness
I've never felt like the way this horse
was just throwing me around and it was
fun until I woke up the next morning I'm
not okay how long was your ride
30 minutes
damn it's a lot of like muscle I was
trotting and trotting it's like you have
to hoist yourself up and you have to
like bounce I'm feeling every bounce is
Snitch as well
no snitch is totally fine maybe that's
because she actually works out and like
for me I was exercising muscles in the
back of my legs that haven't been
exercised since I was in the womb did
Ben horseback ride no hmm he's not into
it you know
yeah I feel like he tries so scary it is
scary but I mean not in such a
controlled environment no actually Ben
doesn't try everything like Ben very
much gives into his fears like for my
21st birthday Ben planned this like
Twisted day where like we went we went
to a trampoline park we went to a
trapeze class and we also went to
somewhere else and in the trapeze class
like you have to climb up this rickety
ass ladder it's like a hundred feet in
the air the latter is the scariest part
of the trip and then once you get up
there you just jump up into the net Ben
went up the ladder got up there and went
back down the ladder which is scarier
than just jumping off I have a image
seared in my mind of Ben hanging from
the thing so that was a different time
so in our family we have this like
inside joke about this one picture of
Ben because uh when Ben was working at
an ad agency like 10 years ago they did
like a team off-site like team building
where they went trapezing and he did it
then and he's wearing this harness and
he's flying through the air and they
take a picture of him it's like a
souvenir and Ben looks so so weird in
the photo like it doesn't even look like
him I think actually Olivia has posted
it on her Instagram before like for
Ben's birthday our family we're obsessed
with this photo you guys when I tell you
it does not look like Ben and he was
wearing this harness that was like
really digging into his hips and giving
him like kind of like a feminine
physique and it's just the funniest
[ __ ] picture
um so that's the image you're thinking
of but when me and Ben trapeze that was
after that and it was he Ben did not do
it by the way you guys are so similar
because that's literally you with the
leap of faith
yeah when we were kids we all went to
Atlantis we used to love Atlantis and we
did the leap of faith and Claudia the
first time we went she did not do it she
never did it with us and then you once
went back with Ben and you did it no I
didn't go back with Ben I went back with
my friends from high school in the 11th
grade and let me tell you something
about that dumb [ __ ] water slide not
worth it don't do it like everyone in
the family was like making fun of me
like you can't believe you didn't do it
I was like okay and then I did it I'm
like this [ __ ] sucks like I got a
[ __ ] wedgie I didn't even get a good
picture of myself going down the slide
because like I was taking pictures on a
digital camera I'm like this is a thing
my sister's like tormented me for for
all these years it [ __ ] blows I mean
it's not
yeah and I took it I was like okay now
what and also it's so many stairs that
when you do get to the top it behooves
you to just go down the slide then go
back down the stairs I actually don't
remember being such a such a treacherous
Journey Down how do you think you got it
up
no I'm saying like I don't remember the
stairs being because you know me like
I'll avoid stairs at all costs but it
wasn't like that crazy of a set of
stairs because if it was I would have
gone down the slide okay I remember
stair it was extremely stiff they were
definitely stairs but they weren't like
crazy steep they were like wide and
shallow no like I remember I remember
life like by the stairs I had to take
you know and I'm almost like 100 sure
they weren't that crazy but think about
how tall the thing is and the whole way
up his stairs so even if they're not
like horrible stairs it's a lot of
stairs yeah it was better than going
down the dumbass [ __ ] slide
okay it was literally so dumb like the
whole trip oh God I'm gonna do it like
shut up I'm sorry I didn't mean to
trigger you we have no actually I'm glad
you brought it up because honestly it
makes the sisters look bad it doesn't
make me look bad like the way everybody
was [ __ ] dragging me to fill the
whole vacation and we used to love
Atlantis we would go back every year and
it was like every year like man we're
glad it shut the [ __ ] up you ugly
wenches okay it's not a big [ __ ] deal
yeah and then I did it and then I did it
when I was like 16 I was like grown I
was like you know what everyone dragged
me like let's just [ __ ] do it and you
know what it was a big nothing Burger a
big waste of my time
yeah but literally carpet burn on my
butthole from the way my underwear went
riding up that's what sisters are for
no like seriously [ __ ] you guys like the
way you literally made me sick you
literally tortured me over this stupid
[ __ ] slide if you don't feel that way
about your sisters at some point in your
life then you're just not sisters no
that's definitely true you know and we
don't really fight much as adults so we
got it all out on the leap of faith we
got it all out on the slide we did leave
it on the slide we should go back really
we felt like Mary Kate and Ashley of
course when we went like the first time
we were so excited that's like whenever
we had a family vacation there was no
place else we wanted to go like living
obsessed it's an amazing Resort it's an
amazing Resort like they really have
everything for the kids for the campers
for the parents like there's casinos so
like right when you take your way back
you can get lit we went back in 2017
right before my wedding for like a
little oh my God I forgot but we went to
The Cove which is the adult Hotel so I
think if we went back to Atlantis proper
now we would think it's like kind of
like gross because it's like it's really
for kids yeah but you have a new
facility called The Cove which is like
adults only think you have to be 21 plus
they have their own pools and it's
really premium no but now like you wait
until you have kids and then you go
again with your kids and and then it's a
whole nother experience again I can't
say enough good things about the
Atlantis even though the new hotel in
the Bahamas where we went for my
bachelorette is giving it a run for its
money but for like the young
professionals crew not families as much
because they don't have a leap of faith
so I yeah I did the leap of faith like
that's all to say
great I'm so glad I did it you conquered
your fears mclared
no I've conquered my fears
especially when I travel with Brian like
he's always like you know
making me face my fears and like it does
feel really good afterwards like you
feel really proud of yourself I don't
remember feeling that with the leap of
faith I actually remember like a feeling
a lot of resentment for like my
childhood trauma I think that's kind of
what took over
um but it is really nice as an adult to
actually face your fears like you with
your driving
yes I'm on the cusp of getting my
license you guys and it's so crazy this
thing that is rewarding the singer has
evaded me and tortured me for like 15
years soon hopefully will be at an end
and then the world is my oyster it's
just a really crazy feeling I can't
explain run away if you wanted to I'm
hoping to well I could always have done
that called an Uber
um I'm hoping to have my paperwork like
by the end of the year that's my goal
and then this will be like the first
time in 15 years that getting my license
is not my New Year's resolution
I think that's beautiful and all it took
was 15 years
good
you know what we're getting into that
time of year especially now that
thanksgiving's over like no matter where
you stand on the political Spectrum like
it's the holiday season before some
people like it's too soon like everyone
no but now we're officially in the
Hollywood of the Hollywood Hollywood
and it's getting it's like resolutions
end of year Nostalgia era and we need to
start thinking about our resolutions I
know I mean I'm a perfect person so I
don't have resolutions but if I did it
would be to
um invest more in myself and speaking of
investing more in yourself today's
episode is sponsored by bowling Branch
the holidays are the most exciting time
of the year and if you want to enjoy
them to the fullest you'll need to get
your best sleep every night it's easier
than it sounds all you need are the
softest most luxurious organic cotton
sheets from Bowling Branch they are made
from the finest 100 organic cotton
threads on Earth they make a difference
that you can truly feel night after
night so we are bowling Branch girlies
my household is bowling Branch as is
Jackie's there's really no greater set
of sheets on Earth Jackie and I both
have the hemmed uh the signature hemmed
collection from Bowling Branch my duvet
my throw blanket my pillowcases my
fitted sheets really everything on my
bed is from Bowling branch and it's just
been a glorious experience as a customer
um because I feel like they're really a
great investment they're get they get
better through every single wash and
they're free from toxins pesticides
harsh chemicals and they're made by
Artisans who are actually earning the
pay and the respect that they deserve so
you know that they're ethically made
ethically sourced and that feels good
knowing that like you're gonna take a
gorgeous snap on a gorgeous set of
sheets that was made the right way you
know and also today's Cyber Monday so
make sure to listen to All of the ads
especially this one because Cyber Monday
you can get a better night's sleep and
gift it to everyone on your list with
bowling Branch sheets so it's 25 off
site-wide plus free shipping when you
use promo code toast at
bowlingbranch.com that's
b-o-l-l-a-n-d-branch.com
that promo code is toast for free
shipping and the entire website is
currently 25 off offer ends December 4th
if you've been putting off kind of
refreshing your bed or you're looking
for a great gift for someone who's like
a homemaker bowlingbranch.com use kotos
for free shipping the entire website is
off uh 25 off for Cyber Monday and you
don't want to miss it today's episode is
also sponsored by Skylight frames for a
really special gift for the special
people in your life you've got to check
out the Skylight frame so if you're
looking for a good gift idea that your
parents or in-laws will genuinely love
look no further than the Skylight frame
a photo frame you can update instantly
by email from anywhere so it's a digital
frame and it's a great way to feel close
to those you love even when you're
separated it sets up effortlessly in
under 60 seconds just plug it in use the
touchscreen to connect to your wireless
network and then enjoy if you want to
send photos to the frame it's super easy
everyone in the family can use the app
or you can email the photos from your
phone and they'll pop up in seconds
multiple people can send photos to the
frame so it's a great way to keep large
networks of friends and families in
touch it's a black frame with a white
mat so it looks like a real photo frame
and it adds a beautiful touch to your
home it's Timeless the vibrant touch
screen lets you swipe through photos you
can even tap to send a little like a
little heart to the person who sent the
photo they have two options in terms of
sizes the 10 inch and the 15 inch I have
the 15 inch and Ben's parents have the
10 inch it's such a thoughtful gift for
parents and even if they're not really
tech savvy it's so easy they also have
100 satisfaction guaranteed so if you
don't love your Skylight they'll offer
you a full refund
as a special offer you can get 15 off
your purchase of a skylight frame when
you go to skylightframe.com enter code
toast that's 15 off your purchase of a
skylight frame when you go to
skylightframe.com code toast
s-k-y-l-i-g-h-t-f-r-a-m-e.com promo code
toast
um I have to say over the weekend we got
like a million posts in our Facebook
group asking for the Skylight frame
code so guys it's uh skylightframe.com
the promo code is chose for 15 off it's
an amazing gift for an in-law honestly
amazing those are really hard to shop
for amazing gift also it's Cyber Monday
like do you have anything that you're
gonna be getting aside from bone brand
sheets and a skylight frame the thing is
when like Thanksgiving or like Black
Friday or even like Prime day comes
around I'm always like I don't need
anything and then like I do need [ __ ] I
really should have started keeping a
list we did that this year
I it's a mistake because I'm like I
don't need anything I'm so blessed but I
really do need [ __ ] yeah we started a
week ago just like thinking of like
things that we need and waiting till
Cyber Monday so the list is only really
two items but important new TV we're
getting that today and I need new
headphones for
um this job here and so Cyber Monday
Cyber Monday back to resolutions
um
I don't think I've actually ever
um
had a resolution that I kept with you
know except like and of course always
every year my resolution is like you
know eat a little healthier
um but I started doing that over the
summer so it's not not really a
resolution yeah it wasn't like a January
thing right I just feel like it's so
cliche you know like I think like making
a change in your life in July is more
impressive than making a change in your
life in January I agree it is pretty
cliche but it's just a good like
reminder to
reaffirm your goals and also just like
to self-assess and be like even if I
don't change anything on January 2nd
just like know what I should change
even if I don't do it like you gotta
know I know like not to be like so
annoying like I really can't think of
anything I really don't like about
myself that's beautiful mclared I mean
I'm sure you could come up with like a
list of things or any of the listeners
like Claudia
you should be a lot nicer
no actually I'm okay
I'm okay no nothing comes to mind the
habit of yours that you could kick oh I
guess like
nah
no I know what you're gonna say no no
but yeah because you could do that
whenever it's not like yeah dependent on
the time of year
yeah no and like I have a plan you know
oh that's nice yeah like you know my
life is I mean you know man plans God
laughs but I have a schedule for my life
a rough idea you know yeah yeah and I
think like when the day comes that I
decide to like start trying to get
pregnant which I don't think is going to
be like super soon but it's not like
super far I think I will leave all my
Shenanigans behind me and until then
like I'm gonna go party like I'm gonna
smoke a vape like if somebody offers me
a cigarette like maybe I'll [ __ ]
smoke it you know like because I can and
because you're that would look really
cool yeah no I mean I want to be cool so
I have no choice other than to smoke a
cigarette
totally so for today's show we obviously
have the fast five stories I'm sure
we're going to talk about Kim and
valenciaga um but we also have TV recap
I caught up on White Lotus this morning
and it's crazy and you watched
Yellowstone correct and I watched
Yellowstone yes another weekend where
White Lotus evaded me but I'm kind of
liking like two birds
let me tell you something about White
Lotus actually it's actually two birds
two stones right efficient I think like
this show and specifically this season
will be so enjoyable to someone who
binges it like nothing really happens
episode over episode but like watching
it all as a unit there's a lot of
excitement but like something finally
crazy happened like the last second of
last night's episode I'm like thank God
for this episode you know
yeah did you watch anything else or read
anything else good this weekend before
we jump in
oh you know what movie I saw for the
first time
age of Adeline oh when I saw snitch was
showing it to you I didn't realize you
hadn't seen it and I had one thing to
say spoiler alert dead cats I was very
very upset when we saw it as kids in the
theater we were
plumped beside ourselves I couldn't
believe Margaret it was a cute movie you
know like I'd never seen it whatever I'd
seen like things about it on Tick Tock I
knew like she never aged or whatever
um it's like Tuck Everlasting with Blake
right I love Tuck Everlasting and wish
reference and with the guy
um Dario from Game of Thrones and
Harrison Ford so it was stacked and it
was very good it was a cute movie but
like I don't know why they had to have
the storyline of her like having
Cavaliers throughout her life and like
watching them die a slow painful death
it was so upsetting and overall I had to
give the movie Zero stars because of it
even though it was like a it was a fine
film
it's yeah it's a fine film that's all I
remember from it obviously it's our
studded and it's a pleasure to watch but
like it will if especially if you are
and it's not just Cavaliers like it's
King Charles Cavalier Spaniels and if
that is your and they're Blenheim if
that is your breed of choice like
trigger warning stay away liberal
trigger warning Mark Jackie the second I
saw the dog I turned to Margo because
I'm like this dog's gonna die because
like oh the dog's not eating like I knew
it yeah apparently there's a website you
can go to called like does the dog
die.com and you searched the movie
you're about to watch just to make sure
like the dog doesn't die and people use
it as like a barometer for what they
will watch and what they won't watch
that's [ __ ] funny I know I when I was
talking on Instagram about how upset I
was about this film somebody messaged me
they were like there's a website does
thedogdie.com that's really funny okay
cool tip of the day tip of the day also
I did get some clarity about the King
Charles Cavalier Spaniel
um and that episode of the crown with
the romanovs and whether or not there
was a King Charles Cavalier Spaniel that
was murdered and there was Anastasia had
a King Charles Cavalier Spaniel and I
read a whole ass book about her and they
never mentioned that so you really can't
trust what you're reading
so true reading is bad on the plus side
there was one dog named joy that escaped
and wasn't murdered along with the
others and went on to live like a royal
life and in England because I was like
they knew he was the little boy's dog
and he got the Royal Treatment over in
the UK so that's beautiful that's
something
um so all in all it was a fabulous
weekend for both of us I conclude
correct yes you may conclude you may
draw that conclusion conclusion drawn
um and I'm excited I have a
we have a lot of stories and I have a
lot of thoughts on the stories me too so
without you further ado
without further Ado where are the stress
Brothers still not here they had a
jam-packed weekend full of holiday fun
full of getting scraps from Thanksgiving
Bruno isn't having us his favorite
holiday year after year he scores big
time
so for that reason the trivia fan will
not allow him to work oh let me tell you
the tryptophan like really hit me this
year I ate and then fell asleep on Ben's
parents couch wow like I couldn't
believe it but how come there's no
tryptophan when you have like turkey
slices
such a good question I think by the way
I was trying to tell everyone oh wait
hold on I have to tell you that like
on Wednesday night
me and Ben went out to dinner and we
actually been out to dinner just us two
in a really long time so it was really
nice and you know we are married and we
do spend like all of our time together
and like when I tell you like we don't
always have like a million things to
talk about like I'm just being honest
um and I brought up every single talking
point from our patreon episode of I was
like did you hear about the beyond meat
farm
I was literally like and he thought I
was like so smart and tell him how I
knew all of this and he never listens to
the toe so he'll never know but I was
literally like we were talking about FTX
we were talking about condom usage I was
like throwing out these like really
interesting stories that we could have
like interesting conversation about
because earlier in the day we recorded
our annual Thanksgiving patreon episode
um and it was like it was so helpful
like for me and I now I'm really
realizing like why people have looked
forward to the episode every year
because like if you cannot think of
anything to talk about and you just
listen to a podcast like you're gonna
talk about what they talked about on the
podcast yeah so true also with holiday
season and just family time in general
that episode is extremely pertinent it's
like stories that are people are talking
about so you can have like a little bit
of knowledge on but also just like some
random stories and factoids that you can
bring up at the table when there's a
dearth of conversation or things are
getting awkward I got so many messages
and saw comments from people being like
literally things got awkward and
political and I brought up the Scrabble
story and it completely diverted the
conversation 100 of the episode is so
entertaining because Jackie was being
like particular really unhinged and
people were eating it up I was eating it
up so it's a great episode to listen to
and we dropped another patreon this
weekend I finally I've Never filmed it
before I don't know why I finally did
like a full video on my hair like from
wet hair to styled hair like all the
products I use my techniques
um so that will live in perpetuity on
the patreon so whenever anyone asks me
I'm like glad I have it filmed now so
it's a vlog and then we have podcast
episode there's one more episode coming
out this month it's just a great time to
be a patreon member totally Zach and I
went on a date night last week we hadn't
been on a date night in six months so
there was a lot to talk about but we
played a really fun game that if um if
anyone who's going on a date night new
parents especially and they're running
out of things to talk about and it's
time to pick up your phones here's the
game find the cutest picture of your kid
on your phone and then we choose who
wins honestly that's so funny it was so
much fun and we played round after round
I saw this Tick Tock of this couple
going out to dinner like for the first
time since having their baby and they
just spent the whole meal crying
um because they like somebody the
husband had like read a quote that like
really like was it like emotional for
him and he shared it with the wife and
then they spent the whole meal crying
one day you're gonna pick up your child
like physically pick him up for the last
time oh I was thinking about that
recently not about picking him up but
there's gonna be like something oh like
one like he was like crying through
breakfast this morning it was just like
random and I was like one day he's gonna
like
he's gonna cry like a baby for the last
time and like the next time you know
like how babies just cry like
unreasonably and the next time like he
cries it will be because like there was
something something happened right but
like not one day I mean I think kids cry
for a while about nothing but you have
stuff to look forward to yeah I always
think about that like one day it's just
gonna be the last time I'm not even
gonna realize about something
what a Heavenly thought
yeah but then you have new things to
look forward to he's going to do
something for the first time puberty
he's going to do something for the first
time everyone just like like don't
settle like you could think of
everything as like sad and like
sentimental negative or like positive
and exciting and yeah optimistic
I will say like when you know God
willing I should be blessed with having
children and they're going through
puberty like I will be leaving until
they they're they're better like I'm so
not interested in like hormones and like
their voice is cracking and like I think
with a girl I could handle it because
like I am a girl and like I just if
she's being a wench like I understand
why and like gets her period like I can
help with that
um but like I'm just literally not
interested in like helping young people
through puberty it sounds miserable even
if I'm related to them yes
but I also feel like I don't remember
puberty as being like that miserable and
not like
Moody for no reason like I feel like any
time like we were all like moody or like
unhappy or had something going on like
there was tangible reasons as to why I
read all these books about like kids
going through puberty and they're just
like monsters for no reason yeah and I
feel like obviously all kids are
different I feel like it's a little over
hyped
I guess we'll have to wait and see and
they say that girls are actually more
difficult to handle going through
puberty boys they have more physical
changes but it's less emotional girls
you're living with like a psychological
terrorist right right no and then like
there's just so many things like bras
pads and tampons like there's lots of
accoutrement I think you'll be surprised
at how equipped you are
yeah because I'm just gonna close my
door like seriously you're gonna act
like that I can't I don't negotiate with
terrorists
okay well now without further I did it
did it do here are the fast side stories
that you didn't do need to know on this
glorious Monday as we Usher in the
holiday season
here we
that yet did it do need to knit it did
it do you do need to knit it to do that
you do you also need to knit it did it
do that today's episode is brought to
you by Thrive Cosmetics they make high
performance Beauty and skin care
products with Clean Skin loving
ingredients this season give gifts that
give back with 45 off Thrive Cosmetics
holiday sets for a limited time so
everyone knows the liquid lash
extensions mascara from Thrive Cosmetics
I bought it off of a Facebook ad like
literally 10 years ago and it's still
one of the best mascaras that I own I
have very straight lashes and I don't
find really anything that helps except
the Thrive Cosmetics mascara like is
that [ __ ] like it's worth all the hype
that it gets so it's a vegan tubing
mascara it's their best-selling product
it's a proprietary tubing formula that
dramatically lengthens each last lash
from root to tip it mimics the look of
lash extensions but without the damaging
glue or expensive Salon prices also
their brilliant eye brightener is a huge
favorite for a lot of people it's a
cream to powder highlighter stick that
brightens and opens Your Eyes giving you
an instant eye lift you can apply it to
the inner corner of your eyes and you
look like you've had a restful sleep
even if you had not you could also use
it as an eyeshadow for a perfect date
time glow or use the metallic shade for
an easy smokey eye it's foolproof it's a
highlighter stick that makes it easy to
apply and blend so Thrive Cosmetics is
great but also Cosmetics is because
they're a cause driven platform bigger
than Beauty so for every product
purchased Thrive Cosmetics donates to
help communities Thrive they have over
300 giving Partners across the country
supporting numerous causes Thrive
Cosmetics actually is a good stocking
stuffer because it fits in a stocking
and it's really like a great gift so
celebrate the season of giving and try
Thrive Cosmetics today right now you can
get 45 off their best selling products
when you purchase select holiday sets by
visiting
thrivecosmetics.com toast that's Thrive
Cosmetics
c-a-u-s-e-m-e-t-i-c-s.com slash toast to
start shopping for the holiday sets
great thank you so much yeah welcome
first story Kim Kardashian has broken
her silence on the controversy
surrounding Balenciaga
so after days we reported on Wednesday
the beginnings of this story several ad
campaigns uh there's a new ad campaign
from Balenciaga and then people went
into the archives and found
former ad campaigns by Balenciaga that
are extremely concerning uh
concerning they are extremely concerning
and they concern child sexual abuse uh
it's been now five days since everything
emerged and Kim released a statement
last night with her thoughts on the
matter she said quote I have been quiet
for the past few days not because I
haven't been disgusted and outraged by
the recent Balenciaga campaigns but
because I wanted an opportunity to speak
to their team to understand for myself
how this could have happened as a mother
of four I've been shaken by the
disturbing images the safety of children
must be held with the highest Regard in
any attempts to normalize child abuse of
any kind should have no place in our
society period I appreciate balenciaga's
removal of the campaigns and apology in
speaking with them I believe they
understand the seriousness of the issue
and will take the necessary measures for
this to never happen again then 40
minutes later she posted 52.
52 minutes later she posted as for my
future with Balenciaga I'm currently
reevaluating my relationship with the
brand basing it off their willingness to
accept accountability for something that
should have never happened to begin with
and the actions I'm expecting to see
them take to protect children
okay so I feel like this is a really
layered issue but I do want to just say
like my overall sentiment towards Kim's
reaction to this is wow like what a
letdown I mean it's not like a hot take
whether this is like right or wrong like
this is uncategorically if that's a word
wrong
um category sure I respect the hustle
like for me like I get throwing your
values out the window for some money
like I really do like I can be bought
but I feel like we draw the line at
child children we draw the line of
children yes so I feel so disappointed
in Kim like her first statement was
trash then she deleted it and
re-uploaded it and added disgusted
literally she added one word then I
guess she saw like the immediate
reaction from people was like you're
kidding right and because she didn't
even address her relationship with the
brand in the first statement then an
hour later put up something like to
appease people and it was still not even
remotely taking a stand and I just
really want to point out like people
being like well I thought you guys are
against cancer culture like this is not
cancer culture like this is so twisted
and sick like no okay like this is not
cancer culture whatsoever like that
would be like us being like against
being uh anti-jeffrey Epstein because
we're anti-cancel culture like right
it's this is a full-blown crime like
let's not get it twisted this is not the
same as somebody and like Beats from 10
years ago there's not I guess we don't
have a line in our society anymore
that's very clear-cut but for me it will
always be like it is do you protect
children are you exploiting children are
is this is so inappropriate for me with
Kim like anything short of I will no
longer be associating with this nasty
ass brand is a big fat nope for me I
really like I'm so
disappointed I guess is the word and I'm
also just like icked the [ __ ] out I also
want to say like this Valencia AGA era
that she was in like doesn't give much
to begin with so the fact that she can't
walk away from it is lame as [ __ ] the
clothes are ugly the looks are done
they're old and they're tired and this
would have been a great honestly excuse
for her to be done with the whole thing
in general because it's been old and
tired for a while sure there's probably
contractual reasons why she can't just
walk away but Kim's a billionaire
[ __ ] figure it out and I'm really
like I find this nasty
no I know and like
I'm and I do want to say like oh and by
the way by the way if I mean not
Balenciaga because they're clearly you
know don't know where the line is with
child sexual abuse but if this was a
brand who had hired a spokesperson and
the spokesperson had behaved nefariously
they would have canceled her in two
[ __ ] seconds so why does it ever work
the other way right the difference here
is like when uh when a spokesperson like
usually we have these situations where
it's like the spokesperson is the one
who's in hot water and the brand can
drop the spokesperson I can't remember a
time in recent history where the
spokesperson dropped the brand so this
is like unchartered territories I was
thinking the same thing and also like
I'm I hate everything that Kim did and I
think it's like it's I agree 100
disappointing but I also think it's
important to remember there's so many
celebrities who work with yes and I know
Alexa Demi Nicole Kidman literally like
I want we have we need to have that
energy for everyone and Kim deserves you
know more of the conversation because
she's Kim no and also like the Alexa
Demi fans can go and hold her
accountable like I am a Kim fan like
everyone else I mean maybe Nicole Kidman
like yeah say something girl I love you
for real like more than anything
everyone else yeah their fans should
hold them accountable and want to see
better from them and the brands that
they associate with for me like that's
Kim for me and so I'm really only
invested in what she has to say because
I care about her in general yeah
um agreed I think this whole Saga is so
weird because you know people on the
internet especially celebrities like
they love to use their platform to like
you know Galvanize around an issue
um and I would say this is a rather
large issue and I just think like the
Silence from every single celebrity
except for Lala Kent is so shocking to
me because I get it like you know in
most situations you don't want to like
drag a brand because you know you work
with them or they give you clothes you
get paid by them but like I feel like
when it comes to children like all that
gets thrown out the window and we all
just do the right thing right and it's
not like it was just the um one the
teddy bear is wearing harnesses and then
photographed with children like not that
I want to make any sort of excuse but
maybe just some like some things like
slip through the cracks and maybe there
are a bunch of dummies there who didn't
realize but this is like so layered and
it goes back pretty far so it's not just
like Kim said like you know they made a
mistake and and they're accountable and
they're gonna do better like this is
kind of like years and years of whatever
predator or predators are within like
and high up at Balenciaga like are doing
this intentionally if you guys haven't
seen all the other evidence that has
come forward it was the Supreme Court
Document on the Adidas collab bag it was
the model in the office with books and
one of the
um
they're like coffee table books and one
of the artists is like known for you
can't even look at the images on Google
they're so perverse and they're blurred
out so there is something there is an
ill and a rot at Balenciaga that starts
very high at the top they want to blame
it on the photographers the
photographers don't get the props they
don't like it's not on them they just
shoot what you tell them to shoot like
they're until this is rooted out like
Kim should not be working with them and
them putting out an apology and you know
oops and next time it won't happen like
it's just once but also here right here
it wasn't even just once so it's like
they released a statement the
photographer released a statement and
every statement is just blaming someone
else but it's like who who yeah no like
they need to do a thorough investigation
of their employees and their
predilections no and I have to say like
Kim Gurley like you know I would really
I would do anything for you but like
this is a huge L on your part like you
need to do way more and like seriously
like I'm kind of judging you like hard
honestly yeah I agree and then I was
over the collab to begin with which also
makes it easy like it's not like I was a
Balenciaga girl it's like a fabulous
moment and yeah it's not like I really
own anything by them but I don't care if
it was Fendi like not Nary an item to be
bought again until this evil is rooted
out also what I find kind of crazy is
like when everything happened with Kanye
and like everyone like dropped him in a
succession like is the real real gonna
stop selling Balenciaga like right
you're gonna need the same energy I'm
gonna need the same energy from everyone
who dropped Kanye because this is
[ __ ] crazy yeah no I completely agree
like
no longer bank with Chase like I I
really feel like
the lack of
if it weren't for people on social media
just regular people with moral compasses
like no one would be talking about this
and it's so concerning because like I
feel like there's a lot of like
conspiracy theories about like Elites in
Hollywood and like celebrities and like
as it comes like like that all they do
there's like a lot of benefits about
like sex trafficking rings and I'm sorry
like those conspiracy theories like are
being hella validated right now because
like the lack of anyone speaking out is
so weird it's so weird and I even saw an
article I haven't like looked so much to
see what some of the like like Daily
Mail has spoken about and whatnot but I
saw an article from like high snibbity
have you seen it's like a fashion site I
think High yeah snob like high snob ID
and it's like the conspiracy theory
surrounding balenciaga's new campaign
like and they said this it was just like
so crazy they were like people are
trying to make it seem like the kids and
the Bears and the Supreme Court thing
we're part of one campaign like this
campaign is it makes it worse and it
wasn't part of the same campaign it
makes it worse that it's just like
sprinkled in over the years right it's
like systemic yeah
oh my God that's a [ __ ] delusional
article delusional
no the way no one's okay that's really
no and you know who it is I feel like
who are really taking up the cause on
social media it's the moms like it's
Lala Ken it's Rach parcel who are like
seeing this and they're outraged no it's
so true it's the moms
100 you don't need to be a mom to know
how [ __ ] up this is right and that's
why I think people are even more
disappointed than Kim yeah no honestly
like
talking about this whole conversation as
it pertains to Kim like she's let she's
really let us all down like this is a
huge
and if there are reasons why she can't
speak out what she can't break her
contract like why don't you talk about
it like the way you're giving us this
like PR bullshitery shocked and
disgusted like it's giving Notes app it
was giving she literally took a
screenshot like on Instagram like she
didn't really put any energy towards it
after five days like I I respect people
taking their time and not just speaking
out immediately like I really do but
after you're gonna take your time I want
to be wowed by your state I want you to
say something yeah to give us nothing
Burger PR bullshittery after five days
honestly I'm so kind of like done with
Kim right now
me too it's not okay and the fact that
she's a mom just makes it even like she
should be even more impassioned and
she's not yeah
so the whole thing is really gross and
who knows what's next but right
valenciagas I mean I it's like it's kind
of the Catch-22 because it's like if I
own a lot of Balenciaga like I'd want to
sell it on the real real because um also
everything like says like I don't want
to be like a walking advertisement for
you it was like maybe like a subtle coat
you know you never know but um I think
the real real should stop selling them
so yeah where does everyone go dump
their Balenciaga stockx
it's the same thing this stockx still
sell easy for sure because there's that
started it's their whole site yeah no
but it was like kind of crazy when real
real even did that with easy so now
you've set this standard right so let's
get the child predators in there too yep
you know what it's called mclared
precedent
you know I love a good president and
they said the president
um so we'll keep you posted on this
story I don't think that's going to be
the end of it no no and I sure hope not
I hope not from the Kim Point like she
might girl he's got to do more I never
thought I'd say this unironically but
she has to do better
no like it better's not even enough she
needs to do more she needs to do
something yeah well right yeah uh and I
think Balenciaga filed a suit against
their photographer
like because they're trying to blame the
person who took the pictures that that
they set it up okay but there's like 500
people who get everything done before
the photographer even clicks his camera
no and there are people like there I saw
a video of this guy from the fashion
industry like talking about how the
photographers are just take the picture
like right and also their most recent
fashion show was kind of demonic and it
had like now everything like that
they've done in the last couple of years
is being looked at it's like why is
everything you do so [ __ ] weird and
dark it's clothes right like weird with
kids there was a very lifelike dolls and
blood oh and the clothes were ugly right
and the clothes just stay ugly
dead
all right for our next story I am
Switching gears
Joe Jonas lost a Spider-Man role to
Andrew Garfield he said he was the right
one so Joe was burning up to play Peter
Parker in the 2012 movie The Amazing
Spider-Man but he lost the role to
Andrew Garfield he said quote I remember
years ago I was up for Spider-Man and I
was so so excited and it was the year
Andrew Garfield got it obviously he was
the right one he noted that the film's
director Mark Webb used to be a music
video director which led the Grammy
nominee to believe that he had an end to
get the role he said but you know what I
love the process of auditioning and
putting herself out there and having to
prove yourself he said adding that he
made it through to the Callback portion
of the audition process as for whether
that included taking the old Spidey suit
for a spin he replied no but I'm sure I
had one that I would try on occasionally
back in the day
let me tell you how I would take a
bullet for Joe Jonas and I don't think
that he's right for Spider-Man no and
did he yeah a guy from obviously Camp
Rock iconic world no he's not really
like that he's in a new movie right now
with Glenn Powell devotion that like is
getting a lot of Buzz it's like another
like Top Gun like plain Navy movie
um
but he's not really like that
experienced in acting outside of the
Disney Channel
right so to go from Disney to Spider-Man
that would be a bit it's a jump actually
Zendaya did it
so true but wait I'm so glad you brought
up the Jonas Brothers because I have
like an extremely hot take that I need
to share okay on Thanksgiving Ben had
the uh Cowboy Giants Cowboys game on and
there was a halftime show in the Jonas
Brothers performed I was like oh [ __ ]
yes love this and they did like a medley
of all their songs you know Kevin was
out there killing it on the guitar Joe
was taking lead vocals and Nick was
doing guitar and like 30 of the vocals
and maybe I haven't seen them perform in
a long time or maybe it was just like an
off weekend for Nick Jonas but like if I
watched that
well I did watch that but like I could
draw the conclusion that like Nick Jonas
can no longer sing from that performance
maybe he was sick maybe he's had a lot
of late nights up with the baby like
there's a million things but the way he
could not hit a note to save his [ __ ]
life and you know him his oh he gets all
the high notes because that's like his
voice literally he would sing and
nothing would come out it was like a
silence on the mic it was so weird and
then I went to Twitter to see if like
anyone was talking about it because I'm
like this is like low-key crazy
everyone's like Nick Jonas is so fine oh
my God he's so fine a couple people were
like wait like what's going on but it
wasn't and I just want to know did
anyone else see that and be like what
the [ __ ] we had the game on but I think
halftime show was while we were eating I
didn't even pay attention to it so I
can't speak to it maybe is it possible
he was having audio issues like feedback
and he couldn't hear himself and perhaps
I'm gonna need to see another
performance from him to like I'm not
gonna make any you know Grand
assumptions but if I wanted to my
assumption would be like this boy can no
longer sing he should get into another
field
I'm gonna say like there was issues
did anyone else see it and anyone else
know what I'm talking about
I'll maybe check it out but I feel like
no you're probably right he probably
stunk up the joint but I don't know what
that means that he can no longer sing in
perpetuity it was just so crazy to me
because like for years like Nick was the
perfect one like he hit every note he
was the most musically talented and it
was just the way like Joe was so
effortless like he wasn't even trying it
was just like sounding amazing and like
Nick was trying so hard like his neck
and his voice like sounded so strained
and he still couldn't even hit the note
maybe he was sick Maybe
I'm a sucker for you yeah that was good
that was like Nick Jonas Vibe maybe you
could take a spot I don't want I will
not go anywhere politely all right that
wasn't great but
I'm a sucker for you that was literally
Nick he's like always like like
clenching I'm a circle for you
so he's always clenching he's always
like straining yeah I'm a circle for you
anyways that's probably one of my
favorite story tropes on this show is
like people who almost got what role me
too and usually I could like really
picture the person in the role I
couldn't honestly not see Joe Jonas as
Spider-Man like not to be rude I do
think he's a little too short
but I get like short vibes from Andrew
Garfield too and Toby Maguire but I
think Joe Jonas is shorter than both of
them like for real yeah also this really
could have changed the course of history
because Andrew Garfield and Emma Stone
then dated because they met on the set
they dated for a number of years after
the movie
that wouldn't have happened maybe it'd
be Joe and Emma Maybe
wait wait so sorry wait I'm
misunderstanding so he auditioned what
like 10 years ago back in the day for
this movie oh not for like the most
recent one with Zendaya no that's with
Zendaya's mans
oh I'm sorry I got so confused for it
because I've never seen any of these
movies okay sorry so back in the day oh
you know what
I actually could see it
right Joe and Emma Stone
yeah no and like
he was so young and like he was like the
big hot thing like I actually I could
see it
last year yeah
and he was coming off of the Disney
Channel now it's been 15 years since the
Disney Channel like it's okay you know
what I actually can see it I'm sorry I
misunderstood the whole story
yeah
so just interesting and then my our next
story is another one of my favorite
tropes of stories which is someone's
coming off the singles list with an
eligible partner
oh you'll have to wait to find out
because we're going to a word from our
sponsor
episode and our singles news is brought
to you by seeds ds01 daily symbiotic
turns out everything you you like that
everything you think you know about
probiotics may be wrong like probiotic
tortilla chips definitely sounded way
too good to be true the good news is
that seeds ds01 daily symbiotic is the
real deal because an adult probiotics
are created equal so the cds01 daily
symbiotic is a broad spectrum
plant-based Prebiotic and 24 strain
probiotic formulated for Digestive gut
immune and additional systemic benefits
the capsule in capsule protects against
stomach acid digestive enzymes and bile
salts providability through digestion
what does that mean the live probiotics
are actually going to make it to the end
of the small intestine for the delivery
into the colon so if you've taken a
probiotic before and you never felt a
difference it's likely because the good
bacteria wasn't surviving your GI tract
seed is designed differently and that's
why it works it supports benefits in and
Beyond the gut it'll support the ease of
bloating Health irregularity
ease of evacuation so you'll be making
nice big soft duties bsds as we like to
call them here at the toast and a lot of
people see improvements in digestion
within just 24 to 48 hours which can
include bowel movement regularity and
ease of bloating so you can start a new
healthy habit today when you visit
seed.com toast use code toast to regime
20 redeem 20 off your first month of
seeds DSO one daily symbiotic it's
seed.com toast and use code toast that's
s-e-d.com t-o-a-s-t code toast for 20
off your first month of seeds ds01 daily
symbiotic thank you mclared that yes D
sponsor
is leading us into our next story which
is at Minka Kelly sparked romance rumors
after an LA date night with Imagine
Dragons is Dan Reynolds looks like Minka
Kelly could be a believer in love again
the actress is sparking romance rumors
with the Imagine Dragons front man after
the two were spotted on a date night in
La over the weekend Paparazzi
photographed the two of them stepping
out to Cafe Stella in the silver lake
neighborhood Saturday night although
there was no blatant PDA between the
pair and the pics obtained by Page Six
he was at one point seen stroking her
hair in their parked car
stop Minka Kelly like
was just born under a lucky star like I
really believe that first of all she's
one of the most beautiful women like
I've ever come across in my life she
doesn't look like anyone else she's
really unique looking she looks like she
looks like other like there's like an
Easter yeah there's a bunch of girls who
look like but like she I'm saying she's
not like beautiful like women now like
who are beautiful and like get big lips
like they all look the same yes okay
like Minka Kelly like actually looks
like a human being not like an alien
like everyone does these days
she is the most I think she has veneers
yes let me look she's the most no don't
look at her veneers look up who she's
dated in the past she is the most
Stellar taste in men like every time she
spotted out with someone it's just like
more she wasn't Derek Jeter right for
like a million years yes mclart I don't
think she has veneers
oh let me look they look like real teeth
like really good veneers look like real
teeth no they look like real teeth for
sure there's this dentist on Tick Tock
who will like take a picture of a
celebrity and like zoom in and tell you
if they have veneers and it's actually
really helpful
can you pull up her dating history okay
not her teeth
no I'm looking at the teeth now I feel
like they're definitely veneers
they're totally veneers maybe I was
looking at Old picks okay she dated
Jesse Williams Josh Radnor Wilmer
Valderrama Derek Jeter right John Mayer
oh right Chris Evans
Donald Faison Brian White Trevor Noah
right but
when did she date John Mayer I think
there's like one photo of them like
getting into a Range Rover um like one
time and
maybe it's like this connection I have
to Friday Night Lights in particular
Lila Garrity which is why I'm so like I
will always keep up with Minka Kelly and
she's so funny because like does she
ever work like she was in Euphoria but
like as a very very small part and she's
like still so famous but like from what
um
from Friday Night Lights from Friday
Night Lights she's just someone that
people care about she was also in the
2018 movie the beach house which I
personally watched Andy McDonald plays
her mother it's a wonderful movie oh is
it like a Hallmark film yeah it's
Hallmark and she's extremely hallmarky
and I feel like she could be more
hallmarky
she like I feel like she had an
opportunity after Friday Night Lights to
literally become America's sweetheart
and either she didn't want it or like it
didn't happen for her because when I
think about the trajectory of her career
like it kind of makes no [ __ ] sense
wait and remember when she played Jackie
O in the butler
no
we watched The Butler remember I
remember and and there's just like a
scene with JFK played by James Marsden
and Jackie O played by Minka Kelly no I
don't remember that but it's a perfect
casting in my opinion yeah
um so like I'm just I would love to do
like I would love an in-depth timeline
of Minka Kelly's documentary where where
things went wrong you know or maybe she
just chose to do less to keep her sense
of normalcy and just like be one of
these celebrities who can like you know
get paid go to Target at the grocery
store holding a certain bottle of juice
and still have her sanity no that would
be really impressive but I just think
like and it's possible that that's what
she wanted or I just feel like something
went wrong in her career because like
Lila Garrity like the way I think
millions of girls wanted to grow up and
be Lila Garrity she really was like
America's sweetheart but don't you also
kind of feel that way about a lot of
like Teen Idols like even like late in
Easter even though she wasn't country
strong but I also like
I would say Leighton Meester is like way
more famous than Minka Kelly
really yeah would you not I would say
they're like the same
no I would say like the way I perceive
it is like Leighton Meester got so
famous off of Gossip Girl like did the
things for a few years and then like is
so famous that she had to take a step
back like I don't think that was the
case for Minka Kelly
like Leighton Meester really is like
nowhere to be seen but she's still so
famous but I also think Gossip Girl was
a bigger show than Friday Night Lights
no we just watched Gossip Girl when it
was on and we didn't watch Friday Night
Lights until later in life at least me
no I watched it when I was in like the
seventh grade no no no
no what it's not something that we
watched in our family I watched it like
with Zach I watch it in the eighth grade
you did I camp I remember I had a DVD a
portable DVD player oh look at you
I'm about that song I did have a
portable DVD player
actually everyone did like it was so fun
like everyone at night like wouldn't
talk to each other we'd all just be like
on our portable DVD players good times
good times
she's dating Imagine Dragons front man
which you love to see it so I didn't
even then get to say my thoughts on
Imagine Dragon front man who's literally
the hottest man who's ever walked the
planet
um I've actually ended up on a side of
tick tock like Imagine Dragons stand up
and there's just like really premium
videos he'd never performs with a shirt
on he's so [ __ ] hot
um and the band is just like huge but
he's not like you know he's not like an
Adam Levine like he has to be like the
face you know he hasn't like sold out
either I feel like yeah real music and
yeah after hit but they don't make it
for the hits and they don't make it for
the radio they make it because they're a
rock they love it no they seem really
grounded as a band and he seems like
he's not like this [ __ ] who's like
the lead singer and therefore it's not
like Josie and the Pussycats you know I
like love this man and he's I'd never
even hear about who he's dating
so much I actually thought he was gay
because I think I saw somewhere like
that he had a pride flag yeah but I
guess he's just an ally so I just I kind
of like love this
yeah loving it as well also you know
that he's like down to earth guy because
I personally didn't know who the lead
singer of Imagine Dragons was because
it's really an ensemble of course you
know like Marcus Mumford Mumford and
Sons you know Ryan Tedder One Republic
like some guys they make themselves
known I just feel like he does It For
the Love of the art
okay I I did know like his name and his
face and everything but I I understand
what you're saying yeah well I'm not as
tuned in as you know not plug as plugged
in maybe if you had a tick tock that you
were passionate about you would know but
you're like no and you don't and I don't
no you don't no I do not how are things
going on Tick Tock what's new
I actually really wasn't really on Tick
Tock a lot this weekend I was just kind
of like enjoying the presence of my you
know friends and family it's so
beautiful how's your book going what are
you reading still the idea of you
so disgusting yuck like she's having sex
with a guy who's 20 years old she's 30
and 40.
um and she keeps calling her my sweet
she keeps calling him my sweet boy and
it's kind of [ __ ] disgusting like I'm
getting so icked out like by this book
and it's like all about you know women
in her 40s reclaiming her sexuality
after divorce but like it's also giving
like a little pedophilia for sure
because if the rules were reversed and
it was a 40 year old man and a 20 year
old girl we would say yuck and he kept
calling her my sweet girl
yuck no she's kind of disgusting so then
so like I can't even get through the
book it's really twisted people like
like this book ew how far along are you
like 40
it's too late to turn back I know
especially with the end of the year
creeping up on us right even though I
already hit my goal my goal was 35 I hit
it and Michael was 50 and then I hit it
again right but now you just like keep
setting new goals so it's your new goal
16. you could do no my new goal my goal
was 50. oh okay so you're done yeah
my goal was 30 and I hit it I think I'm
at 38 now so now my goal is 40. I will
hit that because I'm almost done with
this book and then I have to read the
redhead so
I don't think I could read
I think you could see no get to what 50
50.
I could just because like we're going on
vacation and maybe
it depends it depends what Harry wants
to do on vacation you know yeah what
Harry wants Harry gets yeah so it might
not leave a little too much reading time
for mum yeah okay next story are you
ready yep
Andy Cohen says real houses in Beverly
Hills is taking a break he teases the
Bravo plans for 2023.
Andy Cohen revealed that real house says
Beverly Hills will be on hold for a
minute he said Beverly Hills were taking
a minute break and then we'll be back
shooting with them in the new year
he did not go into detail as to why the
LA based reality show is not following
their usually usual programming schedule
he also did not comment on what child's
wise may be back for the next season so
they will start filming again in the new
year which isn't that long of a break
it's not like a roni size break it is
longer than we're used to from Beverly
Hills they usually start filming right
after the reunion so they got like at
least three months off which is really
nice for them and I think necessary and
they think also they're delaying making
any decisions
right I mean I do feel like it's really
like odd because if it's such a short
delay like why do they have to make an
announcement you know maybe because
there was all these rumors floating
around and so maybe he's just addressing
it and they really are breaking for a
minute and then they'll be back
I mean the most recent season of Beverly
Hills was good I just like I wanna I
feel like housewives are like in their
flop era like I don't know what I feel
like this is like a transitional period
for housewives like with the Roni reboot
and now Beverly Hills being on a break I
feel like the fate of Housewives is like
very much up in the air like people will
always watch it but it's not really as
much of like a cultural like moment as
it was five ten five years ago
I would agree except I felt like there
was so much excitement for bravocon and
the housewives and what the way I'm
feeling now when I think about it is I
feel like it's becoming very fractured
and extreme like there's less casual
viewers people who tune it on who just
enjoy it like either like your Die Hard
you run a fan account you're going to
bravocon you're obsessed or you're
really over it like a former Watcher
that's actually a really really good
point there's not a lot of like Middle
Ground people who who see every episode
but don't have a podcast about it you
know what I mean yeah I do also think
that the Gen Shop Salt Lake City
Scandal like really was an opportunity
to like Revitalize the entire franchise
and like the way the ball was so dropped
like now that I think about it like
whatever footage we have of this season
whatever it [ __ ] sucks
um we're probably not gonna film with
Jen but she's going to jail and her
sentencing is next month so like that
probably is the end of it unless they'll
do like a special like in her house or
something you know yeah they'll probably
do a special but I think for a lot of
the viewers too and maybe this I've not
seen like people saying this but maybe
it's sort of subconscious where it's
like
after everything with Erica and with Jen
and there's and
they just like keep promoting people
like it's just gotten really twisted and
there's a lot of bad things that go on
and come out of the show and it's just I
think leaves people with like a funny
feeling and maybe like I don't know
definitely how I felt about garcelle
maybe I'm just like really protective of
garcelle but like the way her kids were
like so attacked
um and they're like actual miners it
felt like so gross like this yeah and
like nothing is worth that no it's just
a show it's just a show like everyone
needs to calm down yeah so I I feel like
that's what's happening it's just
becoming fractured and extreme yeah it's
just an interesting moment in the in the
Bravo universe and I feel like they can
feel it and they're really trying to
like do something about it
yeah I feel like they definitely are
like doing more shows that like are
outside of house so I was like it's like
a million below decks but they're also
trying to like give the fans what they
think that they want which is like you
know Southern Hospitality girls trips we
have like a million ultimate girls trips
that are still gonna come out and like
right but they're really just like
catering to like they're really extreme
fan who needs more and more and not
working on just like the Casual viewer
who wants to just watch good episodes of
what they start of real houses of Orange
County of Beverly Hills you know so
that's I
I don't know that what they're doing is
going to solve the problem but well I'm
I don't work until no and I also feel
like peacock was like kind of like a bad
thing for Bravo because there was just
this like pressure for more content when
they really should have been focusing on
the show's on Bravo because they were
all kind of slipping like Vanderpump
Rules like so many things were just like
mer and then they just had to keep
churning out more content so they're
finally giving us I mean we've been
asking for years for some sort of
crossover episodes like an All-Stars
Housewives and now they're doing it it's
just like feels kind of forced yeah and
I feel like they're the only people who
are going to watch like an ultimate
girls trip or something like that are
the people who watch all of the
franchises right now so you're already
like having less limited less audience
and it just like keeps getting smaller
instead of expanding
you're not going to watch ultimate girls
trip if you don't watch
regular franchises yeah but you might
watch
um
a show that has some of the ogs who
aren't on anymore because a lot of
people used to watch in those days and I
think that's what they tried them with
Berkshires I don't know how that did
right and we think of those women fondly
like they really are a part of History
yeah so I think they try and do more of
that but I think some of those women
like don't want to be on the b-list show
they want to get back on their show or
they're not interested right because
they are all also out of control yeah
and also the egos that they're like it's
just a lot it's unbearable yeah
you are gonna die the hero or live long
enough to become the villain are you
ready for our fifth and final Story the
final story yeah I'm ready what's it all
about
Miriam Webster Define gaslighting for me
because they have shared their 2022 word
of the year and it is
gaslighting
I feel like we literally predicted this
because not a month ago we had this a
long ass conversation on the toast about
how people love to use the word
gaslighting these days and they don't
even know what it [ __ ] means they
just think it means lying literally
gaslighting which means mind
manipulating grossly misleading when
being downright deceitful is
Merriam-Webster's Word Of The Year
lookups for the word on
merriamwebster.com increased
1740 percent in 2022 over the year
before but something else happened there
wasn't a single event that drove
significant spikes in the Curiosity as
it usually goes with the chosen word of
the year that's pretty interesting the
gaslighting was pervasive that's I mean
I do really feel like Tick Tock had a
lot to do with that because like the way
that first of all that sound like took
over girl boss Gaslight gatekeep repeat
like there it was very much a part of
like Tick-Tock verbiage and then I think
people started using it like in their
everyday lives even though they didn't
really even know what it meant yes
definitely now we're going to talk about
the former words of the year which we do
every year and I always forget them so
do you remember last year's no oh no I'm
sorry this isn't last year this is um
the other top 10 words of the Year oh
for this year yes okay oligarch
what driven by Russia invading Ukraine
people were talking about the oligarchs
a lot okay Omicron
Omicron triggered oh my Adam triggered
next codify
hmm Queen consort that's two words oh
Camilla yeah raid
sentient
cancel culture
is like kind of cringe Nerium is kind of
dumb no Miriam's like a little cringe
like is it the word of the year the
phrase of the year it's the I'm gonna
get the exact verbiage word
um word
um Merriam-Webster Define word for me
next in the top 10 lgbtqia okay I don't
believe that's a word that's an acronym
oh my God good call duh and the next one
is loamy
which many wordal users tried back in
August though the right word that day
was clown I guess that was like a Wordle
Insight joke one day in August funny
people need a [ __ ] life also last
year's word was vaccine
got it okay yeah that makes sense I like
how it went from vaccine to Gaslight
like it's not in indicative like of
America if that ain't us but that's our
literal like prerogative is that the
word that should be the word prerogative
That's My Prerogative tell me why the
way Britney Spears I think covered that
song I don't think it's her song
um and just kind of changed my life what
album was that where she did
stronger than yesterday and then That's
My Prerogative
are you sure that those are oh my God
Spotify is like always asking me for
[ __ ] like I have just like a memory of
like plugging in one CD and getting both
those songs on one album okay so I will
read her CDs in the zone
no get in the zone AutoZone
okay wait
you know not in the zone hold on black
out no just Google what album's stronger
than yesterday is on
I'm
okay oh my God you're like a research
assistant ever oh my God
uh oops I Did It Again album
okay and it's prerogative on there
no
damn not me gaslighting my own self with
my memories that's literally my adult
existence not you gaslighting your
research assistant
I don't think I guess let you how do you
think you did I think you I insulted you
but I didn't guess like you I think you
vaccinated me 100
um so those were the past five and you
said needed to know all of them you
needed to know them but like I'm really
like tired of Merriam-Webster like being
so thirsty like give us a word I know
any word give us a real word I mean I
guess they're just trying to like let
everyone know what the vibe was this
year yeah no but this sounds like most
like popular Google searches not words
right and it's like okay so that should
be Google's year in review
yeah not Miriam like stepping on
Google's toes not Miriam gaslighting
Google
into getting the vaccine
buy an oligarch uh who's lgbtqia
um we still have the TV recap
Yellowstone and White Lotus and it is
brought to you by a new sponsor today
that we're really excited about don't go
nuts this holiday season fuel yourself
with perfect bar the original
refrigerated protein bar made with
freshly ground nut butter organic honey
and 20 organic superfoods perfect bar
has a variety of products like protein
bars little snack size bars that are all
so good and good for you you are sure to
find something you love probably the
dark chocolate chip peanut butter one
that I have in my fridge that is so good
you know I don't really eat protein bars
like I saw usually something I'd go for
but these are delicious delicious a
cookie dough texture that's creamy full
of flavor unlike any other bars out
there and now they come in snack size
that are packed with up to six grams of
proteins and 150 calories so a little
goes a long way
perfect bar knows it will be Love At
First Bite so for a limited time they're
offering you a chance to try their
refrigerated protein bars for free
here's how it works sign up for email or
text upload a picture of your receipt
from your local grocery store and
they'll reimburse you for the cost of
one bar directly into your venmo or
PayPal account pretty cool right all you
have to do is go to perfect snacks.com
toast to get a free perfect bar today
that's perfect snacks.com toast to get a
free perfect bar today happy snacking I
just have to say like
until I got perfect bars and I realized
that like a lot of the bars that I have
in my house are not refrigerated like
that's kind of gross it never occurred
to me I'm so glad that we have this read
today I've been waiting for it ever
since I got my perfect bars I love a
meal replacement bar I love a snack bar
I love the perfect bar snack bars in
particular because they're really small
and they're snack sized obviously but
they're so packed like it takes me
actually like it's not just like I eat
it in one bite like it's rich and it's
nutrient dense and it's really the
perfect thing to take with you on the go
when you don't need a meal replacement
you just need a hearty snack also
they're [ __ ] tasty which not all bars
are I can tell you that yeah so perfect
bars they're [ __ ] tasty do you want
to do White Lotus or Yellowstone first
let's rock paper scissors okay okay and
the winner goes first the winner gets to
choose oh okay but you so it's you go
Rock Paper Scissors Shoot okay
gotcha Jackie won okay I'll go first
sure bye sure bye I sure love doing
these Recaps separately
oh she took her what'd you say you kind
of love doing it I kind of love doing it
one yes I guess you're talking two it's
just like a fun exercise I have the best
time girly love you just know we have 20
more minutes left on our SD cards like
okay it won't be 20 minutes I know I can
do that love ya bye okay Yellowstone
another wonderful episode from our
favorite people also okay this is really
random but you know how during
Yellowstone they use it to promote all
their other shows that are coming up
because
Yellowstone is the most watched show in
America so they're promoting Tulsa King
and they're promoting 1923 which by the
way I'm so excited about 1923 the
casting is amazing Michelle Randolph
like
I'm not okay but I find this is so
Random the volume on those commercials
is obscene like I watch Yellowstone at a
normal Volume Plus it's on late at night
Harry's already sleeping like I keep it
low and I watch the subtitles and then
those commercials come on and they bust
through the speakers does anyone else
notice that or is that just a me problem
also the commercials from 1923 made me
realize I need to finish watching 1886 I
think I have a few episodes left I just
like lost patience because I was
watching me tweak back to Yellowstone so
many great moments such a wonderful show
even when nothing's happening Beth is in
prison I was shook to the core when I
found out her name was Bethany like
makes total sense but wasn't expecting
that but as stated I'm not a Bethany I'm
a Beth then for her to find out that
Jamie has a kid with his little Graco
car seat now that I'm in the market for
car seats and just like up on these
things I thought like oh that looks like
a nice car seat
um obviously Beth has a conniption when
she knows that Jamie had a baby it was
so sad when she was like God gave you a
boy
I just I couldn't and I was already like
feeling warmly towards Jamie because he
got Beth out he he really does his thing
as an attorney you know I thought he was
going to try and like get this girl two
press charges just to [ __ ] with Beth
just because Beth is always [ __ ] with
him but no he did right by his sis he
made a lot of sense as a lawyer and he
totally intimidated that woman into not
pressing charges which is bad behavior
in general but it's good on Yellowstone
where we just want the duttons to stay
winning so that was nice that Beth got
out it was a fun whole thing but did
anyone else okay I don't know if I was
being gaslit by Yellowstone maybe I just
wasn't paying attention last week
because I never heard what that [ __ ]
said to Beth in the preview for last
week they showed us like the in the
recap of last week's episode they showed
us her saying like I'm taking your
husband home with me tonight but I never
heard that in last week's episode and
then Jamie recounted exactly what the
woman said and she was like you can
either join us or he could tell you
about it tomorrow and I was like I never
heard any of this but now I understand
why Beth smashed her with a beer bottle
I just thought she was like antagonizing
Beth a little bit but no she like was
saying some wild [ __ ] [ __ ] to a wild
[ __ ] woman and listen you [ __ ] around
and you find out if that ain't the motto
of Yellowstone
so Beth goes home happy to see her home
with her Mains this wolf drama is no
good the ngos are coming for John and of
course I realized in that instant that
he would pardon his girly who looks like
Piper peribo is it Piper parabelle I
don't think so but looks like her and
it's giving Piper parabo I should
probably check that but then Claudia is
going to be watching me do my recap
being like what the [ __ ] is you doing
let me just look Piper parabelle let's
see if Yellowstone comes up
uh yeah it does
yep it is Piper power bow great because
it looked like her
so she's back with John in his bed even
though she literally said she would not
be sleeping with him and so I'm assuming
that she is because she was like running
around in the middle of the night but
I'm glad I kind of shipped those two and
he needs someone on his side who's gonna
help him like I love that he's cleaning
house but he also needs to do the work
of the governor and he needs smart
people around him and she does seem
smart wow Claudia is struggling to keep
her mouth shut and then there was one
other thing that happened at the funeral
oh my God I can't even talk about it
like I was beside myself it was so
[ __ ] sad so I'm just gonna move right
past that and talk about the one last
thing which was Jamie being a big fat
[ __ ] and getting seduced in one second
by brunette Beth Dunn I think her name
is Sarah Atwood loving that Beth was in
the present she's going to do some
investigation So This Woman's not going
to make it that far into coming in
between the Dutton family but Jamie is
just so [ __ ] dumb I literally can't
someone says one thing nice to him and
he's dropping his pants like get a life
loser okay we're good see you guys next
week
okay like my recap is not gonna be as
long as yours because like Loki like
nothing [ __ ] happens on this show no
and also I was also talking about like I
I don't know if this is just a me thing
but the volume of the commercials versus
the volume of the show was so different
it blows up my speakers and like Harry's
sleeping in the Next Room and they're
playing Tulsa King at an insane decibel
well I'm on HBO so we don't get
commercials right I was just wondering
if anybody else was experiencing that
that's interesting I'm curious to hear
if anyone has a problem okay enjoy I'll
be quick so obviously the only thing
everyone is talking about from White
Lotus last night it's like that hot guy
who looks just like Harry jowsy is
[ __ ] his uncle and I just really feel
like I didn't need to know that and I
definitely need to see the Uncle [ __ ]
his nephew like it was a little gross
um having said that uh it was a decent
episode obviously like Aubry Plaza is
like becoming unhinged oh wait oh I just
saw it like something on Tick Tock that
really blew my mind because so you know
that scene where you know after the
winery and like Aubry Plaza is just like
being kind of nuts all week all day she
tells
um Daphne that like she thinks something
happened Daphne's like listen I have a
trainer yada yada and she goes to show
her a picture of the trainer but she
instead shows a picture of her kids so I
thought she was just like asserting her
dominance being like listen [ __ ] off
like mind your own business we're a
family I'll take care of it but then
somebody else was saying she basically
said I have a trainer and you know
whenever I am in New York yada yada
basically like she [ __ ] her trainer and
he's blonde with um blue eyes then she
showed a picture of her kids and her
older kid was blonde with blue eyes
so people on Tick Tock were saying that
like her trainer is the father of their
oldest kid she was the one who cheated
first like she knows what she's doing
she's not so dumb that Daphne I don't
know I didn't really think anything of
that conversation until I saw it on Tick
Tock and now it makes a lot of sense I
just wanted to share that little nugget
of information in case anybody um was
confused as well
the hookers are really bothering me and
I don't understand why the guy who let
them into the hotel and added them to
his room doesn't just remove them from
his room like he's mad that they're
charging food that they're going into
the sun's room that they're going into
the dad's room okay Sarah why don't you
go tell Valentina at the front desk to
[ __ ] take them off your guest room
your reservation like it's so easy
um they are really pissing me off
because she's obviously gaslighting that
young boy she's gonna steal money from
him
um Theo James needs to pay the hooker so
the hooker can go uh the hookers are
just really annoying me
um I actually don't even think that
hooker's voice is that good like when
she wants to play piano like sheiloki
sucks bring back the other guy who took
Viagra
um
what else happened in the episode oh and
then uh Jennifer Coolidge and her
assistant went to that guy's house and
wherever it was Palermo and they are
definitely nefarious obviously because
he was [ __ ] his niece a nephew but
also because I feel like they they're I
don't know what it is but like they want
something from Jennifer Coolidge like
they're making fun of her I think they
maybe need money I don't know so I'm
just not happy about that because
they're taking advantage of Jennifer
Coolidge when she's in a vulnerable
position other than that the show really
needs to be watched in a binge-like
setting because like every episode one
thing happening is just like not gonna
work for me
um I don't know who dies I feel like at
this point it's useless to speculate
like we'll find out when we find out we
know it's not Daphne because she's the
one who discovers a body but she is
alone on the beach when she discovers
about it and three people die so maybe
it's like her [ __ ] up foursome oh yeah
because Cynthia James is like rubbing
Aubry Plaza's leg and like definitely
wants to [ __ ] so maybe they're gonna
have a foursome because it's a very
tense group they really just need to
[ __ ] it out in my opinion
um other than that
that's all I have uh why does nobody
ever leave the hotel like you're in
Sicily like go on a walking tour I feel
like everyone eats every meal at the
hotel is constantly spending every night
at the hotel like go out
okay I'm good
Jax is back that was the TV recap and
that was our show if I'm not mistaken
I believe it was our show I don't see
anyone else in the langclaim Lang claim
who would who could
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast the millennial Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
that you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast can be found so
Spotify iTunes District public video I
have read a kiss box all the places
we've listened to podcast find us five
star review about how
talented we are hope you guys have an
amazing Monday and we'll see you
tomorrow on Tuesday yeah goodbye because
that's how the days of the week work
that is how the days of the week work
yes thank you love ya bye